>> Sean: GREAT ANALYSIS.
THANK YOU BOTH.
HERE WITH MORE REACTION FORMER
HAWAII CONGRESS WOMAN AND
DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENTIAL HOPEFUL.
I DON'T THINK YOU ARE A DEMOCRAT
ANY MORE.
I'M CALLING YOU AN INDEPENDENT.
ALL RIGHT.
SO HERE WE HAVE TWO WEEKS BEFORE
THE ELECTION, THIS LAP TOP SHOWS
UP.
IT'S IMMEDIATELY DISMISSED BY
EVERYBODY, RUSSIA
DISINFORMATION.
NOBODY LOOKED INTO IT.
EVEN 51 FORMER INTELLIGENCE
OFFICERS, AH, IT'S RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION.
TURNS OUT IT IS TRUE.
MEDIA LIED THE WHOLE TIME.
AND I JUST OUTLINED 12 SEPARATE
INSTANCES WHERE WE CATCH JOE
BIDEN LYING SAYING REPEATEDLY
DURING THE CAMPAIGN, I HAVE
NEVER TALKED TO MY SON, NOT ONE
TIME ABOUT HIS FOREIGN BUSINESS
DEALINGS, YET WE HAVE PICTURES
WITH JOE BIDEN, HUNTER BIDEN AND
SOME OF HIS FOREIGN BUSINESS
PARTNERS.
I CAN ONLY IMAGINE WHAT THE
MEDIA REACTION WOULD BE IF IT
WERE TRUMP.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THIS MEANS FOR
THE BIDENS, ESPECIALLY NOW THAT
A GRAND JURY IS ASKING WHO THE
BIG GUY IS AND WE KNOW IT TO BE
JOE BIDEN?
>> WELL, SEAN, THE BIDEN FAMILY
CORRUPTION ISSUE IS A VERY
SERIOUS PROBLEM.
I THINK IF YOU POINT TO ALL OF
THESE EXAMPLES, IT POINTS TO AN
EVEN DEEPER MORE SERIOUS PROBLEM
THAT POSES A THREAT TO OUR
DEMOCRACY.
THAT PROBLEM LIES IN THE FACT TA
YOU HAVE THE MAIN STREAM MEDIA,
YOU HAVE SOCIAL MEDIA, YOU HAVE
GOOGLE WHICH IS MUCH MORE
POWERFUL THAN SOCIAL MEDIA, AND
YOU HAVE THE SECURITY.
YOU SAW 51 SENIOR LEVEL
INTELLIGENCE OFFICIALS ALL
WORKING AS THE ARM AND MOUTH
PIECE FOR THE WASHINGTON ELITE,
THE POWER ELITE.
THIS IS NOT A REAL FUNCTIONING
DEMOCRACY.
WE SEE DICTATOR SHIPS THAT ALSO
HAVE ELECTIONS BUT THEY HAVE
ALMOST TOTAL CONTROL OVER THEIR
MEDIA AND IT MAKES IT VIRTUALLY
IMPOSSIBLE FOR ANY OPPOSITION
CANDIDATE TO CHALLENGE AND WIN.
SO WHEN WE LOOK AT WHAT WE'RE
FACING HERE, IT'S NOT SO
DIFFERENT.
THEY DECIDE, OKAY, BIDEN'S THE
GUY WE WANT TO WIN.
HERE'S THE INFORMATION THAT WE
WANT VOTERS TO SEE.
WE'RE GONNA SHOVE AWAY AND HIDE
ANY INFORMATION WE DON'T WANT
THEM TO SEE.
THEN WE, AS VOTERS, HAVE TO MAKE
A DECISION ABOUT WHO WE'RE GOING
TO VOTE OR OR NOT OVER WHAT IS
ESSENTIALLY PROPAGANDA.
THIS IS POWER HRAOET.
THAT IS WHAT POSES AS A THREAT
TO OUR DEMOCRACY THAT WE ALL
NEED TO BE VERY CLEAR EYED THAT
WE'RE DEALING WITH HERE.
>> Sean: SO WE HAVE ZERO
EXPERIENCE HUNTER GETTING ALL
THIS MONEY, ALL THESE DEALS WITH
CHINA.
$100,000 SHOPPING FREE.
$30 MILLION DEAL AS CHRONICLED
BY PETER SCHWEITZER.
WE KNOW HE GOT 3.5 MILLION FROM
A RUSSIAN OLIGARCH, FORMER FIRST
LADY OF MOSCOW.
MONEY FOR A SPORTS BAR.
THEN WE HAVE BARISMA PAYING
HUNTER, NO EXPERIENCE IN OIL,
GAS OR UKRAINE, IS GETTING PAID
MILLIONS, HIS COMPANY.
THEN JOE LEVERAGES A BILLION
DOLLAR OF OUR MONEY, SAYS YOU'RE
NOT GETTING IT, YOU HAVE SIX
HOURS BARRING THAT PROSECUTOR
INVESTIGATING MY SON OR I'M
HEADED HOME.
SON OF A B THEY FIRED THE GUY.
NOW, THAT LOOKS LIKE THE REAL
QUID PRO QUO WITH JOE TO ME.
IT LOOKS LIKE THE BIDEN FAMILY
COMBINED WITH ALL THAT MONEY
FROM ALL THESE COUNTRIES.
I HAVE A PRETTY GOOD INCLINATION
THAT THEY KNOW ALL ABOUT HUNTER
BIDEN, HIS CRACK ADDICTION,
WOMEN OF THE NIGHT, I'LL CLEAN
IT UP BEST I CAN.
I FEEL LIKE THE PRESIDENT IS
LIKELY COMPROMISED.
AM I WRONG?
>> THIS IS A SERIOUS ISSUE.
IT HAS TO BE INVESTIGATED.
THIS KIND OF CORRUPTION
SHOULDN'T EXIST WITHIN OUR
GOVERNMENT AND UNFORTUNATELY IT
DOES AND HAS FOR A LONG TIME.
AS WE APPROACH THE 2022
ELECTIONS LATER THIS YEAR, AS WE
APPROACH THE 2024 ELECTION, WHAT
I REALLY WANT TO REDIRECT
PEOPLE'S FOCUS AND ATTENTION ON
IS THIS FACT THAT YOU HAVE THE
WASHINGTON ELITE THAT IS
ESSENTIALLY CONTROLLING WHAT WE
SEE AND HERE.
THE REASON WHY THIS IS IMPORTANT
FOR US TO KNOW IS BECAUSE WE AS
VOTERS HAVE TO BE ABLE TO SIFT
THROUGH THAT PROPAGANDA IN ORDER
TO FIND AND RECOGNIZE THE REAL
TRUTH AND INFORMATION AND MAKE
THAT BEST INFORMED DECISION SO
THAT WE CAN GET RID OF THESE
POLITICIANS WHO ARE PART OF THIS
ESTABLISHMENT AND CONTINUING TO
PROPULGATE THIS NONSENSE AND
INSANITY POSING THIS REAL THREAT
TO THE EXISTENCE OF OUR ACTUA